during that postseason
you had a moment
against the Padres
and uh
is probably one of your most
embarrassing moments I would assume yeah
and tell me tell me about it tell me how
what happened okay so um
as we leave from LA from beating the
Brewers in the first Wild Card round
that we had that year
um
one of my molars gets infected I had a
root canal Crown gets infected and
I start hurting I talked to the doctor
and I was like Hey My My molar's killing
me man like I have a crown and like it's
killing me for no reason he's like oh
everything you're saying sounds like you
have an infection we'll send you some
antibiotics the only problem is
diarrhea is a side effect and I was like
man like
I have diarrhea every other day it's not
new it's fine and
he's like all right well go ahead
sure enough I get I get diarrhea and on
like my third day of being in this
medication we are
we're in a big situation we uh I had
come in the game to pinch it for
somebody so I was in the game as a DH
okay out of all the positions I play I
was the Aging yeah so I'm in The Dugout
I get to lead off the next inning so I'm
like full like elbow guard batting
gloves I don't have my helmet on because
it's not time yet whatever we're on
defense and uh
we punch out
I think it was uh D May was pitching I
think we punched out Manny to get out of
the inning and I let go of it yeah [__]
yeah those emotions made me like make my
body like push you know because I'm
flexing I'm excited
and level four comes out okay I'm like
oh [__] I think I just [__]
punch my ass real quick I think I just
[__] so were you were you were you at
this point were you concerned or you
were like you know what I gotta go don't
even I had to lead off the inning that
was the third out there was no time it
was either that or tell doc hey dog I
can't go take me out
can't say that if I'm not dying I'm not
getting into that game yeah okay
sure enough I go to a plate
uh my lower half is a little more
slippery than usual a little squishy
and uh did that help it did not help at
all man like
we all know I have some trouble focusing
on a daily basis and that just did not
allow me to focus I punched out in three
pitches against Garrett Richards I'll
never forget I go in the dug I go in the
look Dugout I tell doc as I'm walking by
like in front of him in the Dugout after
striking on three pitches in the playoff
game I was like hey dog I just [__] my
pants bro
I don't think he believes me so I go
straight down I take my batting gloves
off I take my helmet I put my bat and I
go running upstairs
and I tell I yell at Alex look Alex I
think I need some sliders to this point
I haven't realized we're wearing white
yet
I get in the toilet even think about it
no no not even I I just knew my [__] but
I was a gosh I got two pairs of Sliders
they'll hold up you know
I get in the I get in the toilet I take
all my [__] down and I see a big stain a
little more yellow than my shirt
on
on the sliders on the sliders I was like
oh [__] I start dying already I'm
already sitting at the toilet you know I
can do whatever I have to do and not
worry about a thing
but then I'm like oh [__] we're wearing
white and I like
put the sliders to the side sure enough
it was on the fan the same stain that is
on my sliders was on the white pants
on National Television
no I threw those out I got two brand new
pairs from Sliders from Alex
I was like Alex I don't know what to do
with his pants so he's like just throw
them there like we'll we'll figure out
how to wash them and I put a different
pair of white pants and uh yeah that was
a story I made it a little longer than
maybe I should have but it was it was
part of the process of the story like I
wanted everybody to know what I was
going through and then the spring
training
um
the Red Sox were doing a social media
thing and
I was doing it with JT and he got to ask
me what the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to me on a baseball
field and I was kind enough to share my
experience with people and let let
everybody out there in the world know
that we're normal people and that [__]
happens too you know literally and
um dude wives heard about it dude wipes
dude so you gotta you got okay keep
going and they reached out to him they
reached they actually tweeted
hey have your team reach reach out to
our team
and I was like Hey guys like look at
this what are you waiting for reach out
I got I want baby wipes we got a deal
done and we uh
got a lot of baby wipes or dude wipes
not baby wipes and uh I got a little bit
of cash and
it's a it's a beautiful you gotta pay
for pooping in your own pants
[__] happens man don't hate the player I
hate the game or the antibiotics I guess
oh yeah or the antibiotic you know
there's a lot of things I would do and
that's not one of them not on purpose at
least
I can't even imagine I'll be sweating I
mean man but yeah bad didn't last long
so oh yeah you're in it I made it fast
you're in and out yeah I wonder I wonder
if anybody saw it like on the Padres I
don't I mean I mean you would probably
it probably thought you sat in some dirt
or something right right
calving and match their uniforms too